on va commencer avec le Ward de l'humain
encore plus malaisant que Gilles Verdez
regarde
dans la catégorie de l'humain encore
plus malaisante que Gilles Verdez les
nommés sont Jean et Laurence pendant
leur voyage à Rome
o
Maxime face à ses futurs ex
beaux-parents
Éric le genre de type qu'on oublie sur
une aire d'autoroute à cette magnifique
journée on a passé que la boîte
je suis là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de les revoir
[Musique]
1 2 3
là tu dépasses un peu quand même hein
j'estimais qu'il fallait pas que je
reste même j'ai peur d'être un poids
pour elle vu qu'elle est pas mal occupé
en ce moment
[Applaudissements]
incroyable talent et l'amour est dans le
prix
de gros succès pour eux c'est quoi on
dirait on dirait Greg Guillotin en fait
le garantie c'est un truc de fou et on
va Éric gostet par Agnès et Christian ça
aussi
j'ai l'impression que le choix d'Agnès
il s'est porté sur Eric
Christian pardon
cette magnifique journée on a passé que
la boîte
je suis là
quelle saison on a d'autres extraits
franchement c'est incroyable pour vous
c'est quoi l'extrait le plus mallédon
on continue avec le World du j'aime pas
trop ta troncher tard regarde
dans la catégorie j'aime pas trop ta
tronchera les nommer son Nathalie et
Laurence avec l'embrouille du bouquet de
fleurs ouais j'ai un choix
Nathalie et Laurence avec l'embrouille
sur la quiche lorraine
avec l'embrouille au karaoké
[Musique]
c'est vrai que ça c'est fort ça c'est
fort c'est fort le bouquet j'aime bien
moi le karaoké pour moi j'ai presque
envie de le revoir le karaoké
[Musique]
c'était qui m'obsède jour et nuit
L'Amour est dans le pré tiens le work du
moment aussi chaud que la culotte de
Daniel
alors on va les mettre
vraiment unitaire parce que c'est là
qu'on voit mieux c'est beaucoup mieux
regardez il y a Alain
il fallait faire l'amour tous les jours
sinon on casse la machine comme tu es la
première arrivée mais c'est toi qui
choisis la chambre que tu veux si tu
prends la mieux et en fait j'ai
peut-être aller dormir avec toi
à un moment donné que ça se bouge moi
j'ai un zizi il est énorme en fait
[Applaudissements]
regardez
je suis triste de partir
c'est que je vais te revoir bientôt
[Musique]
pour moi et pour toi
non mais c'est comme ça
[Applaudissements]
exceptionnel des stars cette saison il y
a que des séquences comme ça cartonné en
saison 17 comme ça c'est pas fort
[Musique]
mais le balconnu tu as vu je m'y connais
moi il est toujours fleuri
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là il a peut-être ça y est il a
peut-être une il y a une ouverture avec
une Mireille et je lui souhaite tout le
bonheur du monde mais bon pareil mon
épaule est là s'il y a besoin
Daniel Mireille non c'est quoi ton
deuxième prénom toi Monique Monique
[Rires]
3e pour moi au féminin
qui rattrape non mais c'est fou
mais non mais alors mais je peux te dire
alors quand elle tue des nouilles
toute ta vie hein c'est incroyable oui
oui c'est mon deuxième prénom masculin
moi André toi aussi tu as beaucoup de
choses
on a le Ward du j'ai décidé de Liège sur
la langue française
regardez
le premier
s que les cirés c'est bon ou pas
je regarde pas en fait tu crois que je
vais pas
[Musique]
je sais que gibule là il est dans sa
tête elle rigole quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'ailleurs le contrôle de la situation
c'est hyper bizarre
ça fait peur un peu
je crois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un dernier à la regarder la piscine
ça c'est incroyable
moi je suis à la plonge et je fais 8h du
matin 19h je fais la vaisselle fraise
journée et avant j'étais agent
d'entretien je travaillais à la piscine
à chatte et à la piscine je faisais 6
heures 9 heures
la piscine à chatte
[Applaudissements]
voilà pas dans la pour finir voici le
World de l'image ADP de l'année c'est
maintenant l'image ADP de l'année
vous l'aurez dans un instant l'image a
des pays de l'année vous allez voir on a
du très très loin est-ce que vous voulez
en voir déjà une première c'est Laurent
ces gens devant Nathalie après pour moi
pour moi c'est pour moi voilà pour moi
c'est en fait partir
[Musique]
vous pouvez embrasser votre cavalière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un peu comme le vélo ça revient un
peu naturellement pour le coup
encore c'est un peu comme le vélo ça
revient un peu naturellement pour
[Applaudissements]
Nathalie la plus grande galoche de
l'histoire de la galoche qui a kiffé
cette galoche
je m'exerce un peu c'est vrai
[Musique]
vous pouvez embrasser votre cavalière